bien écouté les témoignages sont nés
alors d'ajustement alors satine toi bats
ta saison aujourd'hui un coup tu me
racontes nous ce qui s'est passé éclaire
charles vous allez voir le témoignage de
sa team c'est forcément pas la seule
et c'est une porte parole de ce qui peut
se passer sur steam donc alors non
effectivement je suis très très loin
d'être la seule et c'est ça qui est bien
malheureux donc en fait je venais de
faire un saut à skis d' y avait une
certaine notoriété qui se construisait
du coup bas autour de moi et il se
trouve que du coup je m'étais mise à
faire des tic toc c'était les tout
débuts de tik tok je m'en souviens très
bien parce que ça buzz est énormément
donc je me suis dis pas je vais faire
comme tout le monde je vais faire des
tic toc
j'en fais je fais des compilations que
je publie sur ma chaîne youtube et à
partir de là j'ai eu énormément de
pédophiles qui sont venus vers moi qui
m'appelait qui m'envoyaient des vidéos
de masturbation des photos commencent
alors commencent à arriver tout de suite
c'est vraiment c'est alors en fait
l'histoire c'est que moi j'étais très
jeune vraiment enfin très jeune dans le
sens où j'avais 11 12 ans et en lui
offrant cette charge à ce qu'on dit
c'est vrai qu'il ya des enfants plus
jeunes qui ont accès direction la ctcc
le problème j'avais wayans toussaint est
en fait c'est terrible quand on reçoit
ça quand on a 11 12 ans comprend pas
forcément sais même pas ce que c'est
vraiment la sexualité on sait tout juste
et en fait c'est ma mère qui gérait mais
comptent souvent et je les gérer aussi
de temps en temps et quand on tombait
dessus avec ma mère on en rigolait
beaucoup parce que c'était la seule
manière en fait pour moi de pas vraiment
resté traumatisé de tout ça même si
quelque part ça me marque énormément je
recevais des messages des choses des
choses terribles en fait mais de
personnes vraiment très âgées il y avait
donc sans vraiment décrire mais quel
genre de choses pour voilà pour qui ils
me demandaient des vidéos de mon train
m'a masturbé et c'est alors que j'avais
vraiment 12 ans et c'était vraiment part
je pense il devait y avoir bien une
cinquantaine de personnes voire house
ah ouais c'était et on a même porté
plainte voilà par exemple parce que
quelqu'un sur twitter divulguer toutes
mes informations personnelles et m'a
menacé en me disant j'ai des vidéos de
toi nu devant ta webcam pour tu ne
changes quand tu sors de la douche je me
masturbe dessus je vais les poster etc
si tu ne fais pas c'est si tu ne fais
pas ça on a porté plainte on n'a plus
une nouvelle de cette personne a encore
heureux et c'est terrible c'est terrible
pour un enfant de 12 ans disent ça et je
suis très très loin d'être la seule et
tik tok est vraiment là enfin c'est
vraiment le centre en fait de tout un
réseau de pédophilie mais qui
c'est vraiment traumatisant je trouve
enfin de savoir que ça existe où je sais
c'est terrible j'avais j'avais des amis
curité dans le même cas goût des copines
avons des amis j'ai pas vraiment d'amis
influenceurs j'ai en tout cas j'ai une
amie à moi qui étiqueteuses et qui fait
aussi face au problème du coût de
l'hypersexualisation j'ai des amis même
pas forcément connus qui reçoivent aussi
des vidéos comme ça et aidera donc c'est
pas que tik tok
mais là en tout cas on parle de tik tok
et c'est vraiment un vrai problème et
c'est quelque chose où il faut agir au
plus vite parce que l'hyper
sexualisation et constante sur tik tok